a metro police officer attended last  week's protests at the capitol  but he claims he didn't go inside as  first reported by the review journal  pictures  on officer christopher cooney's facebook  page identify him as  being at the event the las vegas police  protective association says it is aware  that an officer attended the rally  though not identifying cooney by name  the union says  that he watched the president speak then  walked with the crowd to the capitol but  left  before the violence sheriff libardo told  8 news now earlier this week any officer  who went inside the capitol during that  riot would lose their job